[Musique]
certes heure de fort à lamoura les
heures 1953 par butt petit coeur avec
john ford mode boddicker disait à propos
de gêne ford le plus difficile avec kane
pendant un film c'est de le faire
descendre de cheval
j'adore être admis dans son vrai nom est
forte c'est pas ça du tout son vrai nom
c'est newton ford
c'est bizarre il en a changé ça sonnait
pourtant bien moyenne au québec
et puis ses parents ses parents
déménagent et s'en vont aux états unis
s'installent là va lui à l'université il
joue déjà au théâtre et s'aperçoit il
s'aperçoit qu'ils cèdent mémoriser les
textes et donc il a envie de faire
l'acteur alors il va pas tu es avez-vous
dit va faire lecteurs enfin pas tout de
suite il va d'abord il fallait freiner
de will rogers est contents ils sont
encore à dead
alors ensuite il va faire des petits
rôles à la columbia jusqu'à temps que
l'on me donne bien sûr le rôle plus
important notamment un prénom de mon
rôle dans un western où il est content
il emploie daddah avec randolph scott
qui les desperados de charles vidor
et puis ensuite il retourne et des
villes de plus en plus important ça va
devenir une vedette mais la guerre
éclate à une focus laguérie cac
elles sont un peuple à la guerre éclate
est bon et on l'oublié un peu ça va être
quand il est de retour de mobiliser la
cote n'est plus là c'est sa copine riz
thaï world qui va l'imposer dans ce
fameux film noir devenir un
chef-d'oeuvre gildas et là c'est parti
pour glenn ford va devenir une grande
grande taille sera extraordinaire dont
en flic ensuite teigneux le règlement de
comptes de fritz mans il sera professeur
remarquables comme on aimerait en voir
plus souvent dans graine de violence de
richard brooks qui sera aussi formidable
en cover
quand j'étais à chef de bande d abuser
dans 3h10 pour yuma de noir et je puis
dire bon ben maintenant et bien bon sa
carrière un petit peu dégringolé mans
fred est encore très très très bien très
bien quand il est le père adoptif de
superman dans superman de richard donner
en 1978 côté coeur on peut dire côté
coeur il a épousé la splendide actrice
et leur peau elle il en a divorcé une
foxer marié trois fois trois fois et il
est encore vaillant anglais mais son
dernier mariage sa remontée il avait 74
ans allez voir si toujours veillant à
dada dans le désert cour du fort alamo
au niveau de notre coeur nous venons de
voir le déserteur de fort alamo que
réalise votre batterie choeurs en 1953
et john ford et gm ford et votre voiture
ne feront que ce film alors qu'ils
avaient un projet qui était intéressant
ensemble qui devait s'appeler révolte au
mexique
tourné en relief mais finalement ça se
passe dans des films qui le fera car
glenn ford va faire une chute se casser
la figure et se péter quatre côtes
ceci dit ben bostic heures comprendrait
très bien une fois parce que lui arriver
à peu près la même chose voyez vous
c'est un type qui est devenu réalisateur
mais par excès dans ce qu'au départ
c'est un joueur de football
professionnel
mais va se blesser et partir se reposer
au mexique où là il va découvrir les
joies de la tauromachie et devenir
matador ce joli et bars ensuite rentrer
aux états unis il va être engagé comme
conseiller technique pour le film de
robben familiales à rennes sanglante il
va prendre goût au cinéma et de mes
réalisateurs et enfin 1944 1950 il va
tourner quelques chez nous sous le nom
de la scarpe du coeur quand on n'a pas
joué la moindre pause et mieux ça vaudra
il a tort parce qu'il ya 20 qui est pas
mal dans le low carb rupa lara bon
thriller c est ce qu est une femme enfin
votre boutique heures et surtout très
très très connu pour le fameux cycle 17
western qui l'a fait avec randolph scott
wolf scott était aussi bien interprète
que producteur citons quelques titres
comme ça la chevauchée de la vengeance
le courrier de l'or c'est un mât à
battre le fameux camion stationné bon la
fille dans ce western très j adams jr
amsel a démarré aussi dans les westerns
et oui dans les westerns des radios
eastern vraiment amochée oui les films
est vraiment petit budget puisque alazet
six en cinq semaines
elle était ultra d'aller jamais le temps
de descendre avec toujours en plus les
mêmes costumes aux genoux pour elle la
universal et la remarque et le langage
pour tourner des westerns
elle va jusqu'à lundi 8 heures plus tard
à ankara d'âge dire un peu plus si bien
qu elle le dit elle-même quand elle a un
petit chariot western et qu'elle sortait
dans la rue chanson du style qui sentait
tout nu enfin après après cela après le
journal c'est à dire eh bien eh bien
nous verrons un autre aurait stern jeu
syrie puis ce sera seul contre tous avec
jiraya et john p
un cheval sauvage
c'est la dernière séance deuxième partie
le retour
[Musique]
et
mieux alors on va voir un western
western de 2,54
seul contre tous avec den du rail à et
john payne par john payne oui il est né
dans le montana et sa maman et soprano à
la libye
lorsqu'on s'est monté à cheval ont fait
du western lorsqu'on sait chanter on
fait des comédies musicales est bien
john payne nuit phrase les deux oui il
va chanter dans week end à la vanne en
1941 de walter longue et puis ensuite
viser 50
une fois des tas de petits briscard
vraiment sympathique et dj mais dès
qu'on tue par exemple 4 étranges
cavaliers
daren brown qui était formidable ensuite
il va quitter les écrans et devenir
producteur ça va lui réussir là c'est
très bien se passer va s'acheter un
ranch dans le montana et puis à la fin
de sa vie il aura même un très beau
domaine en californie a appris que mon
fils ne pourra jamais offrir à ses côtés
d'anne raya il travaille d'abord dans la
publicité puis devient acteur de théâtre
il débute au cinéma en 1941 il va
reprendre le rôle qui a déjà créé sur
scène avec la vie père de william wyler
aux côtés de bette davis c'est un
spécialiste déroulent de violents il
maltraite dans la rue rouge de fritz
lang
joan bennett ça lui vaut un courrier de
fans par paquet les petits malins des
studios vous continuez à l'employer dans
ce genre de rôle
il va par exemple brutalisé even de
carlo donc pour toi j'ai tué de robert
siodmak finalement la brutalité
c'est le secret de son succès à doria
vous allez reconnaître lee van cleef
c'est facile il est surnommé landreau
profil d'aigle ne s'en plaint pas du
tout d'ailleurs lee van cleef puisqu'il
déclare que c'est grâce à mon physique
que j'ai toujours travaillé à leur
niveau le clip débute au cinéma en 1950
pendant 15 ans il va être troisièmes
couteaux il va mourir à la première ou
la deuxième bobine dans des films comme
règlement de comptes à ok corral de john
ford john ou encore le train sifflera
trois fois de fred zinnemann c'est grâce
à sergio leone qui va devenir une
vedette avec quelques dollars de plus ou
encore le bon la brute et le truand il
va rester en italie va être souvent un
chasseur de primes dans des sous
produits comme la série des savates à
alto est en faillite et au tournant dans
l'ouest le vrai avec seul contre tous
réalisés par geci j'hésite
et bien ici c'est un petit met en scène
ils étaient 20 en assistant pour
atteindre son boulot dans 20 ans quand
il serait metteur en scène
en fait il est devenu metteur en scène
il a fait des petits chine ouais le
petit western sympa avec le petit oliver
fui en trop qui l'a fait ben chevauchée
avec le diable il a fait aussi l'étoile
brisées où elle terme à tout était
absolument parfait on verra ça on verra
ça on verra ça maintenant et après
qu'est ce qu'on verra et biographe un
bel épisode de série tv
alfred hitchcock présente quand intitulé
and so died rehab ou jeans car c'est une
recette n soda il ya bull chine ce cas
de robert stevenson avec claude race et
charles bronson belle affiche vos menus
non c'est vrai qu'en attendant on va
regarder
seul contre tous donc de juger avec john
payne et ben du rail à
l'ouest je retourne que western
spaghetti mon petit doigt
[Musique]
porté par le nom d'alfred hitchcock la
série a énormément de succès elle est
nommée 17 fois aux emmy awards
l'équivalent de nos sept d'or et on
obtient 2 en 1962 la série change de
format elle devient leur alfred
hitchcock passant de 30 minutes à une
heure l'épisode de ce soir est réalisé
par robert stevenson c'est un anglais
nous lui devons la première version des
mines du roi salomon en 1937
vingt ans plus tard il est engagé par
les studios walt disney il va faire des
films que vous connaissez tous comme
mary poppins claude reims lui débute
comme acteur de théâtre puis il passe au
cinéma en 1933 il va être nommé quatre
fois aux oscars pour des seconds rôles
à ses côtés de charles bronson de son
vrai nom charles munch fils qui il
devient charles bronson en 1954 sur
l'aigle solitaire delmer daves en 1968
le voilà enfin vedette dans il était une
fois dans l'ouest où il est l'homme à
l'harmonica
pour sergio leone l'histoire de notre
épisode de ce soir est inspiré de ray
bradbury
il est célèbre pour ses chroniques
martiennes au cinéma il est aussi le
scénariste de johnston pour moby dick
mois john huston jeu-là nord
alors nous voulons le voir donc un
épisode de la série télévisée al faraj
que le présente
n'est ce pas alors il ya peut-être une
chose que vous avez remarqué c'est que
il ya parfois des images qui
disparaissent puis une autre action
arrive une autre image appareil d'une
façon un peu bizarre parce qu'il y avait
des pubs à l'époque aux etats-unis nous
en france on les a pas vues elles ont
été coupés et ses pubs est amusant c'est
que c'était alfred hitchcock lui-même
qui nous présentait et quand je dis les
présenter ouais c'était par exemple je
ne sais pas le package et yves était
présentée par alfred le papier q c'était
alfredo ses bras et elle a évidemment
comme alfred avait l'enfant d'humour les
essais en deuxième ou troisième degré ça
plaisait pas aux publicitaires et puis
se sont calmées parce qu'ils se sont
aperçus que les ventes grimpent eux
comme quoi le choix du scot était aussi
un excellent commerçants c'est normal
puisque avant d'être l'homme de cinéma
que nous connaissons tous il a été
dessinateur publicitaire
c'est même lui qui a dessiné son célèbre
profil qui apparaît en début et en fin
de chaque épisode est maintenant comme
alfred hitchcock je vous souhaite une
bonne nuit et à bientôt chers amis de la
dernière séance
[Musique]
et